[Music]
I'm not spoken to you since the whole
event spent two years since what since
we spoke a lots happened sure in that
time
[Laughter]
what do you refer to that period for
yourself so funny I'm sweating no it
wasn't it might have been the tank the
the period that you went through what do
you refer to that as is it I was calling
it a meltdown then I could I sort of
changed my perspective and I'm calling
it a melt forward melt forward yes yeah
we're you melted right and then me then
I harnessed it you harnessed it and you
you you the liquid poured for 20 mercury
volcano like a mercury volcano yeah you
shot downhill with no brakes no brakes
you said some interesting thing it was
nuts you said date you blamed Dave
Chappelle for your meltdown what's the
logic of blaming Dave Chappelle
I still hold him responsible to explain
that they're there but a couple things
in the media there was a watch stolen at
the Plaza there was another event in
Vegas there's a couple things going on
that I was you know I was enjoying my
weeks off from that other show and and
so they were already you know sort of up
in arms about my behavior and then I'd
never seen a sketch he'd done on his old
show on Chappelle's Show yes you said so
use your watching ask at mr. Kane Kane
k1 it was the wit where he doesn't know
that he's Bo that's right he's a what is
he is a blind yes yes white supremacist
doesn't know that he's real act comedy
yeah greats yeah and so you watch that
sketch for the first time I laughed
myself into a ruptured hernia yes and I
had to go to the hospital writing the
show thought that that was an OD and
blah blah blah and I still got a little
thing that if I dressed like bulges out
bulges out you know I'm not gonna do
that to you no no dying to see it yeah
no I'm cool
thank you I don't want to see you thank
you so okay so Dave Chappelle partially
responsible they fired me based on the
hernia heard around the world
okay you also blame testosterone cream
want to talk about that I can only say
that don't smoke that stuff were you
using testosterone cream at the time
yeah yeah I was yeah they said a dollop
the size of a quarter and I thought them
in a quarter ounce so using a lot of
testosterone and crazy and crazy and
rubbin and just like again let's do this
thing what have you doing not sure and
and yeah nuts like on this this elevated
platform of like uber vision okay so you
were right it up is what you were saying
you were Reuter died and raised from a
Dave Chappelle sketch yes I didn't know
that's a dangerous combo by the way yeah
I didn't know that it would metabolize
into a store idle effect okay and but I
was kind of buffed at the time also well
okay during this period of time one
mentions that I was bought Thanks
working my butt off you know at the time
there was it just captivated the world
people were talking about it to the
point that Hugo Chavez who is no longer
with us
right sent out a tweet at one point
about you contrary to reports Charlie
Sheen is not welcome in Venezuela there
are limits
Wow Wow and that's not an insult that is
an epic compliment yeah
yeah